The result comes back and when the result comes
back the client box is executing some process C2. The
kernel has to switch to this client, so that is
can see the results, an continue with it's execution. So
this context switch, is again in the critical path of
RPC latency. So if you look at RPC call, the
two contact switches that are in the critcal path of
RPC latency. There's a context switch that happens here and
the context switch that happens here. So only two
context switches are in the critical path of the latency,
the context switch that happens on the server machine
when the call comes in, and similarity, the context switch
that happens on the client machine when the results
come in. So this context switch that happens on the
client machine to keep the client machine Utilizied, can be
overlapped with the network communication to send the call out.
So in other words, this context which is
not the critical path of RPC latency and
therefore do this context which, while the RPC
call. Is in transmission on the wire. So while
overlapping the context switch that happens on the
client box after the call has been sent
out with the communication time on the wire
for the opposite call. Similarly on the server side,
once the server is completed execution and it is
ready to send the results out, send it out of
the wire and in parallel with sending it out
in the wire, it can overlap The contact that happens
here in order to keep the server box busy
doing useful stuff, S2, S2 that can be overlapped with
this network communication. So, only this contact switch and
this contact switch are in the critical path of latency.
So, we can reduce the number of contact switches
down to two. Originally we started with 4, we
can reduce it down to 2. By observing that
the context which is that happened on the client end
box and the server box to keep them utilized
can be overlapped with a network communication for sending
the arguments over to the server, or sending the
results over to the client. Of course we are greedy.
Can we reduce it to one? Can we actually
reduce the number of context switches Down to one. Let's
think about this. So we said that when this RPC
call was made, the operating system on the client side
said, well, this is a blocking semantic, and therefore,
this guy is not going to do any useful work, so
I'm going to block him and wait for the results to
come in. So this context switch that c, the operating
system did on the client side Was essentially to
keep this client box from being under-utilized, but do we
really need to do the switch? Well, it really
depends. If the server procedure is going to execute for
a long time, then, you know, this client box
is going to be under-utilized for a long time. And
in that case, it might be a good thing
to context which in order to make sure that we
are utilizing the resources that we have. But on
the other hand, If, suppose, this RPC call, we know
that this RPC call is going to come back very
soon. And if it is on a local area network
and the server procedure that is going to be executed
is not going to take a long time. Then perhaps
that RPC call will come back very quickly. If that
is the case, we can get rid of this context
switch that we talked about here. In order to
keep the client box busy, we did this context switch.
Don't do that. We can spin instead of switching
on the client side. And if you do that, then
the client is reading but is not being context
restored. It is just that the box is underutilized, so
the only context which that we incur. Is the context
which on the server because you never know when an
RPC call is going to come in. So when an RPC
call comes in, you obviously have to contact switch into
the server context in order to execute the call. That's
the necessary evil. We'll incur that. But on the client side,
what we're going to do is, we're going to spin instead of
switching so that. Even though the box is underutilized, you're not
doing anything on the client side, just sending the call
out and waiting. And in that case, we've gotten rid of
the second context switch that you need to incur. Because
another context was stalled and therefore this context switch which we
said is in, inevitable, because. It has to be done
in order to receive the results for the client. Well, we
can get rid of it if we never switched in
the first place, and that's the trick here. To reduce the
number of conflicts which is down to one, we can
spin on the client side instead of switching so that we
can be ready to receive. The results of
the RPC call execution when the server is done.
Again, the intent here is that we wanted to
the latency that is incurred in the RPC call.
And since these two contract switches were in the
critical path of the latency, we would really like
to see how we can elimintate at least one
of them. And this context which is inevitable and
this context which we can eliminate, by spinning on
the client side instead of switching in the first place.